you're one of the co-founders and heads
of feminists for Liberty which is trying
to you know kind of grow the
understanding of individualist feminism
and whatnot do you
um do you find that
um do you find that that message is
growing or is there also I mean I guess
maybe it mirrors a split on the
conservative right of people who seem
people who call themselves libertarian
or are libertarian and seem uh
increasingly hostile to feminism or to
uh kind of you know increased autonomy
for women uh and the choices that they
make
if it's growing or if it's just getting
more vocal but like you know as sort of
as you said mirroring the the split with
the conservatism it's been the big split
within libertarianism about whether or
not you know
Libertarians in their forward-facing
capacity should be tolerant of various
Lifestyles and you know sort of say like
yes the beauty of libertarianism is that
it allows people to live all these
different ways which is which is what I
think you know as much as you know uh I
you know think that
women's autonomy and everything is great
um you know I'm not going to tell people
like oh you you need to you know live
your life you need to have your
relationships in this model you need to
have your family being raised in this
model like I think that that's you know
an important thing that everyone needs
to figure out for themselves but there
definitely is this strain of of
libertarianism that's that's getting
louder that um at least on the internet
not not that I really encounter in real
life uh that that very much believes
like no actually like we should take
explicitly socially conservative
positions um you know we're not
necessarily saying the state should you
know mandate these but we should
definitely pick a side in the culture
war and argue that really strenuously
which I think is you know that obviously
Libertarians are going to have lots of
different positions of the culture award
I'm not saying we should be quiet about
them by any means but I do think that
it's it's a bad idea for libertarianism
as a whole to sort of make that Central
to our project to pick a side of the
culture War you know
and I think that's one of the things
you'll find with just the feminist for
Liberty is that while we are stressing
you know certain certain positions we
are very much still holding the
libertarian line of you know it takes
all you know we want we want women to be
able to make their own choices we want
people of all dinners to be able to make
their own choices we don't want to force
these decisions on anybody you know and
this goes to a kind of question of
libertarian paternalism I suppose where
people like Cass Sunset and Richard
thaler said you know what there's going
to be incentives built into every kind
of policy
um why not tip them in ways that make
more sense or you know you know that are
that are kind of better for society
recognizing it's always hard to
determine that but should should this
state be encouraging or discouraging any
kind of family formation any kind of uh
you know kind of personal living
situation
don't think so I don't think that's fair
to prioritize yeah any particular
um lifestyle over another because you
know those are matters of people's
people's values and choices or sometimes
they're not you know sometimes they're
just matters of circumstances and we
shouldn't be penalizing people one way
or the other because of the way that
they're either decision they made or the
way that their life turned out in that
and
capacity
um I do think it's changed just to you
know kind of get at one of the things
Scott mentioned about you know this is a
this should be a marketing campaign for
conservatives you know this should this
is this because this is a matter of
values and and the things you were
talking about with the 1950s too you
know like
um
I read recently that the divorce rate is
actually lower now than it has been in I
think like five decades and you know I
was saying that to someone a social
conservative recently and they were like
well yeah but that's because fewer
people are getting married in general so
like you know we're still investment I'm
like yeah but but again like this is how
we're looking at it like do we want
people just to be getting married just
because or do we want people to be
getting married that are more wanting to
get married and able to be in happy
marriages the same thing with fertility
and I think we can argue that you know
because we have more
choice in these matters because we've
loosened these cultural constraints
around the idea that everyone has to get
married everyone else have kids the
people who are doing it are a lot more
stable are a lot happier are going to
produce happier you know individuals and
happier families and and better
well-adjusted children I think that it's
it's fascinating to think about on the
right there is a broad you know there's
a broad discontentment with the choices
that people are making because yeah no
they want I want people to get married
and have kids and and be younger or
whatever on the left that takes the form
of I just read a great essay called Ugg
capitalism where it was a critique of
left Wingers who just everything that
they dislike about the current moment
they just say oh that's like capitalism
that's and It ultimately
um you know we have these broad
ideological camps that are just mad at
the fact that a lot of people make Life
Choices or have preferences that they
don't agree with and instead of you know
for me I mean the only way out of that
for sanity was to kind of be libertarian
and be like you know you know we live in
an incredibly varied society and world
and that's kind of great and we're
bringing in more types of people and
sanctioning people to live and to think
and express whatever they believe and
that's all great and it means like
you're gonna you know you're gonna
encounter a lot of stuff that you
wouldn't necessarily prefer but it you
know for the same reason that they can
you know dye their hair whatever color
they want or live in a throuple or or
you know not get married it means you
you have a little bit more space to live
the way that you want and overall that's
that's pretty good
yeah this makes me think so of the um
the Catholic integralists
um you know that want the state to
enforce
um their their version of uh the good
life uh sort of it's somehow the thought
never enters their heads like you guys
are a tiny minority uh of the population
would you how would you like to see the
uh the the rest of the country uh impose
and sort of have the state impose
um its values on you uh which they
probably would argue it does to some
extent but but I think your point uh
about libertarianism is absolutely well
taken here yeah
bottom line in in all of this fertility
stuff is just that you know when what
we've seen in countries with like hugely
diverse cultures political systems you
know all around the world and just all
these any difference you can imagine
what we've seen is that when you give
people the the choice to have you know
the technical ability to have less kids
and the choice to have less kids a large
percentage of them are going to take it
people are still wanting to get married
people are still wanting to have kids
but people are wanting to have smaller
families that's part of the live stream
conversation that I had with Scott
Winship of the American Enterprise
Institute and Elizabeth Nolan Brown of
Reason talking about whether or not the
state should encourage people to have
more babies if you want to see the full
conversation go here if you want to see
another segment go here